I don't mind the ads I don't mind the
buffer but when the ads buffer I suffer
that's good you may be a poet and not
even know it
[Music]
haven't done a responding to comments
video in quite a long time so I'm
excited to see what questions you have
for me will you be tackling health
questions and fun questions Kuehl if
your shirt is tight that you look like
an intelligent stripper actually Rachael
Ray said that could be one she said I
look like a Chippendales dancer
um yeah like my shirts fitted you can
show off your physique everything I work
for in the gym in the kitchen by the way
I'm vegan right now it sucks I mean I
didn't say anything yet you'll see the
results in my 30-day vegan video coming
soon Matt Kenny what's the deal with
your presentation in South by Southwest
how come we didn't see it it's actually
an awesome presentation I partnered with
Vox media and 3m talking about the power
of silence I did a whole video dedicated
to this subject the idea of silence
needs to be incorporated in our lives
and 3m is making some amazing strides in
making this happen like they even talked
about on stage how they make our commute
quieter so that we can have time to
ourselves in the car when we're not
being attacked by employees and job
duties and social media I think the
brain needs silence every now and then
Taylor how tight do you want your shirt
Mike yes okay I do take my stuff to the
tailor some of the stuff actually this
this is fresh out the back out the back
why ella ella ella [ __ ] it's the Beyonce
song or no Rihanna
oops I have a question I've been getting
my period for three weeks straight is
that Alright Ella that is not alright
there's something abnormal going on good
reason to talk to your doctor about your
cycle questions that you should be
prepared to answer how long has this
been going on how long's your cycles
last regularly are they regular are they
irregular are you sexually active is it
possible that you may be pregnant
you come ready with all of these
questions in mind it'll make for an
easier doctor's visit for you James STFU
I know that stands for James yo Mike I
know you're Russian spy bro I'm watching
you know I'm not broke as if you would
have known I would have already ended
you trust me not a spy like it here much
better yeah Mike works hard but is sure
we're
harder what's with the shirt stuff man
stop getting on me why do you think I
wear a tie it's cuz the buns are about
to say pace bag of cheetos s he attack
he's a snack but most importantly he got
nurses back damn right I got my nurses
back I defend them shout-out to all the
nurses I work with and CMAs cuz y'all
don't get enough love I don't know why
I'm doing this accent maybe cuz I did
that pros Kerby can you do a video on
premature gray I need to do that sadly I
don't know if you can tell I'm pretty
mature grain I'm in my 20s and I have
gray hair sad
Sonia collab with glam core please this
is happening we've exchanged Twitter
messages I love her content it's super
fun to watch I really want to collab but
I dunno she's taking a personal mental
physical health break from YouTube which
is totally awesome
I support creators and doing this they
know themselves they know their limits
hey dr. Mike what's the correct way to
stop a bloody nose tilting my head back
and swallowing the blood makes me
nauseous thanks that is true Annika you
do now want to tilt your head back
because swallowing that blood will not
only make you nauseous but it can wreak
havoc wreak havoc it can wreak havoc on
your digestive system causing diarrhea
or constipation so what I recommend for
my patients to do is to tilt our head
forward pinch at the base of the nose if
you get something cold there too that
will help because ideally what you want
to do is pinch the blood vessels off so
that less blood gets to the area
therefore you'll be better another
little life hack you can get a nasal
spray like one of those constricting
nasal sprays for congestion spray one of
those bad boys in it'll shrink the blood
vessels and therefore you're gonna have
less blood flow and you'll lose less
blood Peter
Ola hi Mike I'm just wondering what car
slash cars do you own Peter a great
question cuz I absolutely love cars I'm
actually driving my childhood dream car
at the moment an Audi r8 Spyder it's
actually funny to say that because I
used to have an Audi TTS back in the day
I crashed that car because of a spider I
have to tell that story on my channel at
some point if you're interested hit it
below in the comments
unicorn love hey Doc I feel hard and wet
down there even when doing simple common
things may I know why I love your videos
some of us get attracted to things and
that's okay but myself times - what are
your thoughts are women choosing female
doctors do you think it is silly to be
shy about seeing male doctors I don't
want to say it's silly cuz everyone's
entitled to have their own thoughts and
anxieties and so forth but I have spoken
to women and recently as you'll see soon
in our collab video I spoke to Molly
Burke I will actually say I prefer when
men do it I find because they don't know
the feeling they'll never know it they
can't say they're actually more
sensitive in my practice we try and
still the fact to our patients that each
of our doctors is well trained and
capable of seeing any sex but if they
have a very strong preference we'll try
and accommodate to the best of our
ability ich ruse eat a can of Pringles
and go to the sauna yeah I don't quite
get it
I love saunas though I'm actually gonna
make a Wednesday checkup dedicated to
saunas if your game your game hit me in
the comments sauna me Pringles
no Pringles just me sauna yeah and I
heard if you had to move to another
country where would you move to love
your videos by the way thank you oh
where would I move I would like to move
somewhere where they speak English as a
first language because that will help
I like Australia I like their climate
it's warm there's lots of sunshine
pretty isolated so bad people can't gate
I don't know where I'm going with this
Australia is my answer Golden Teague
enter is it okay to sleep with a fan
pointed at you I heard it can cause a
stroke of some sorts this is really good
I don't recommend having any kind of
cold air blowing on you for an extended
period of time including air conditioner
or fans or a window open even while
you're driving a car the reason being is
if you over cool a muscle in your neck
let's say if the fans blowing on your
neck all night and you constantly have
this cooling sensation on your neck and
you're already sweating because it's hot
you're gonna over cool that muscle you
need out less blood flow to that muscle
so it's gonna contribute it and it
spasms on you you can have a very stiff
neck so one of the first questions I ask
my patients that come in with a stiff
neck is did you just drive for a very
long period of time with the window
open have the AC blow on you or a fan
happens quite often beast girl do
weighted blankets really help with
anxiety please like so he can see I
really want to know do they treat
anxiety no I mean let's be realistic if
it was that simple I would just be
prescribing anxiety or way to blankets
to all my patients I think what I like
about weighted blankets is there's some
kind of innate human feeling of having
something a little heavier on you that
the blankets not gonna just fly off and
it's warm personally I like heavier
blankets even in the summer when it's
hot but I think making claims that they
help with medical or mental health
conditions it's going too far
IRA Nixon I think dr. Mike has not named
Mike I'm not my true name is actually
Mac I love our shop ski wonder if people
knew that Louise Herrera hi dr. Mike can
you explain the whole man flu phenomenon
domen experience signs and symptoms
worse compared to women I have heard
this somewhere and there was a study
talking about how men complain more
about their symptoms or when they have
the same exact symptoms say that it
affects some more why this happens I'm
not sure I want to say men or babies but
I feel like I'm being unfair to men I
would say I have witnessed this and I
also will say that men don't like going
to see the doctor so that if they're
coming to see me something really must
be wrong or a woman in their lives have
encouraged them to go see a doctor
Frank masazi dr. Mike what's your blood
type
I'm a - I don't know my blood type is
but I think if it should be anything it
should be a positive because I'm an A+
student be positive because I want to be
positive okay moving on David a bass
shoot you should do a collab with James
Charles he would adore you so much he
will probably want to marry you David I
appreciate the compliment and I'm a fan
of James Charles him and I have also DM
he's a pretty awesome human for being 19
years old and accomplished everything is
accomplished it's really impressive
especially being a positive person diana
Capano hi dr. micha Maurice a nursing
school grad and we touched upon the
ethical issues of slow codes what is
your personal perspective on the issue
and did they talk about this in med
school
Diana great
question for those of you who don't know
slow codes is when you when someone's
heart stops and they call a code blue
and they're essentially are dead and you
have to revive them slow codes is when
you believe that a patient shouldn't be
revived and the patient and the patient
or the patient's family is making a bad
decision where you don't necessarily do
everything you can to revive them
because you don't think it's in their
best interest I'm not a fan of this
personally because I think everyone has
a choice in their health care and if
they choose to make that choice on their
own or they choose to have the families
make that decision I think that's in
there you know that's their right it's
their prerogative it's my two cents
question why do I keep getting cold
sores do I know what I can do to make
them stop or why even get them well
generally speaking if you're getting
cold sores you have herpes
it's herpes simplex it's a virus that
stays dormant inside your body unless it
breaks out in a form of a cold sore now
if you've got one cold sore that means
the virus is with you for life and will
occasionally pop out when you're
stressed when you have a weakened immune
system like if you have a virus a
bacterial infection and so forth my
recommendation to you would be talking
to your doctor about how you can stay as
healthy as possible which is focusing on
all your lifestyle habits and then if
you're still getting outbreaks very
often you can talk about a medication
which is an antiviral medication which
prevents these outbreaks and you could
take it daily not just when you have an
outbreak in order to reduce the number
of outbreaks that you do get Dom the
alien have you seen an increase in
patients or people trying to become your
new patients since you started your
channel I have seen that it doesn't
happen as often as you think more often
what happens is a patient is in a room I
walk in and they're so surprised to see
because they watch the YouTube channel
but then reaching out on their own
doesn't have done often and in general I
tend to not accept new patients because
my patient panel is so full but there's
plenty of great doctors in my practice
that are accepting new patients I think
you're gonna love this playlist that I
created just for you my favorite videos
of 2019 so far click it click it and
stay happy and healthy